what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today i'm going to
be giving you my thor love and thunder
spoiler free no spoilers here review i
got the opportunity to attend the red
carpet world premiere of thor love and
thunder about two weeks ago and these
are going to be all of my thoughts now
thor's my favorite superhero i think
most of you know that and this movie is
exactly what you would expect it to be
it's a taika tt chris hemsworth thor
movie it's
outrageous it's out there it's insane
it's radical it's hilarious
but it's also emotional at the same time
it's it's pretty amazing however it
doesn't come without its flaws i do have
a little bit a few issues with it which
we will talk about in this video of
course however i did truly love the
movie so let's talk about thor love and
thunder and a big thank you to elgato
i'm really really happy to be partnered
with them they make my studio look a
million percent better you can check out
the gear that i use in the description
down below okay so to start this off
this movie is definitely a movie on its
own i know a lot of us go into mcu
movies expecting all these connections
and a bunch of different things to
happen and maybe a bunch of different
cameos and stuff like that um while
there is some really amazing things in
it and there are some really cool parts
to it just watch it as its own film if
you watch it as its own film it's going
to be fantastic to you and then some
certain parts will blow your mind there
are some really crazy parts to this
movie that even for myself i was like
wow i cannot believe that we are seeing
this right now it is a movie of its own
but having said that
there are some parts that really make
you feel
the heaviness and the gravity of some
parts of the mcu and they really do show
you that the mcu is bigger than we
actually know it to be now some fans
have talked about how phase four might
not be you know the biggest yet not like
the infiniti saga but trust me after you
watch thor love and thunder you're going
to start to kind of see
how it's all going to get connected and
how it's a lot bigger than we actually
imagined so that is something i truly
enjoyed about this movie was it wasn't
really in your face but there are some
parts that you're like wow what am i
seeing here this is amazing so look
forward to that now one thing i will say
about this film is the plot is amazing
but it's also very well hidden sometimes
marvel studies has a tendency to kind of
show you the whole movie in a trailer
didn't have that with thor love and
thunder there's a lot of great parts in
the trailers but there's a lot of
amazing parts in the movie that they
don't actually show you on the trailers
which is nice because let's say for
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
they kind of showed us a little bit too
much there with the illuminati doesn't
really do that for thor love and thunder
so expect to see a lot of scenes that
you haven't seen in the trailer now the
fighting is something that i truly
enjoyed something about just storm
breaker and mjolnir both kind of going
at it
fighting with each other jane foster's
the mighty thor chris hemsworth's thor
valkyrie korg everybody together it's
just really really cool and to see them
fight gore and gore's powers the way
they did gore's powers are like really
really cool and visually
awesome and the whole fight scenes just
every fight scene in the movie
is pretty much awesome if i had to give
my personal opinion on this which is you
know that's pretty much what this review
is it's it's some of the best that we've
gotten from marvel like really it's some
of the best and i was going to talk
about this later but i'll talk about it
now cgi is on point
it it there's never one scene that i saw
in this movie where i was like oh uh cgi
is like kind of spotty there like we've
done for some disney plus shows or you
know maybe some trailers that we've seen
recently nope cgi is 100 on point for
thor 11 thunder at the end there's a
pretty cool fight scene
that is visually stunning that i think
people are going to really like but i'll
talk about that in just a bit jane and
thor
the chemistry between them the
relationship between the two of them
don't worry they do talk about it they
do go into detail of kind of what's
happened we barely got a little glimpse
of it in avengers end game where thor
you know is talking about he's not with
jane and then it was thor ragnarok where
he says like you know i dumped her it
was a mutual dumping they go over that
so don't worry
but the chemistry between natalie
portman and chris hemsworth was
electric is that corny to say it was
awesome they they really are just so
great on screen together and now that
she's the mighty thor it's even better
and i really like the direction they
took the story with them a little
unexpected but i loved it i actually
have zero complaints about the
relationship between the two of them it
was amazing now the acting
it's a star-studded cast list i
it's exactly what you expect it's
fantastic everybody does an amazing job
but if i have to give it to anybody
christian bale
wow if you were worried about gore
because i know some fans worry because
when they first showed gory doesn't look
comic accurate you know he doesn't have
like the head tails and everything like
that
which recently an interview i guess one
of the one of the writers or somebody
from you know a producer or something
said that they didn't want to do that
because he looked kind of like voldemort
a little bit too much
um and i've seen the memes comparing him
to voldemort but
do not worry about gore
like seriously don't worry about gore
probably one of the best marvel villains
that we've had so far really he's got to
be a top five uh favorite marvel villain
of mine right now because he did it it's
just such a good story
and the way that he fights and the
effects around him are amazing and
christian bale just knocked it right out
of the park which that's what you expect
from christian bell same thing with all
the other actors you would expect them
all to just do their job and be amazing
actors which they are
zero complaints about any of the acting
at all and sometimes you do get some
complaints but
this was spot on this was really really
spot on now overall
i enjoyed the movie very very much a lot
of people have asked me to compare to
ragnarok i have to see it again i just
have to see it again i've only seen it
one time it comes out this week but so
far it is one of my favorite marvel
movies is it the best
no but when you're comparing it to
avengers end game and infinity war and
spider-man knowing home you know it's
really hard but it's definitely up there
with them so it's a great movie and i
think everyone's going to love it i love
it unless you didn't like thor ragnarok
if you didn't like thor ragnarok this
might not be for you because this goes
beyond that it takes it even wilder even
crazier so that's all i'll say about
that now for the parts that i didn't
kind of like
there were a few corny parts in the
movie um
i didn't think there were too many jokes
and all of the jokes kind of hit they
they land i laughed every time but there
were a few corny parts a scene
in particular at the end which i won't
say because obviously spoilers but
at the end you're gonna see a scene and
you think wow that's really cool it's
visually really cool i like like
watching this right now
i might have went a different direction
though with kind of like an indian fight
scene not the indian fight scene but you
know towards the latter half of the
movie fight scene it's really cool to
see and it's funny and it's kind of
charming but i still think they could
have went in maybe a different direction
with that and then there are some scenes
with uh i'll just say olympus
and you know the greek gods and
everything that they're introducing in
this movie there's a scene that i
thought would be different
and maybe that's why i was so thrown off
because i thought it was going to be
different you might go in and think it's
fantastic and again i won't go into
detail one so i don't spoil it but two
so you can make your own opinion about
it um but it threw me off a little bit
when they're at olympus um they
talk to people and do things that i just
didn't think were gonna be in this film
and it kind of threw me off but i'm
curious to see what everybody thinks
about this so when i do my spoiler
review i'll give my full thoughts on
this and i hope to hear what you all
think about that in the future now
overall i'm not going to rate this movie
yet i'll wait till my spoiler review
because i have to see it again but as
far as the thor movie goes it's pretty
dang fantastic i talked to a lot of
people after the film was shown to us
and pretty much everybody loved it
thought it was amazing i think it's
hilarious but one thing i do want to end
on is that like i said it doesn't have
too many jokes yes there's a lot of them
but there's also some very serious
moments in this movie that make you
really emotional i actually cried during
the movie
from like sad and touching moments
and i think that says a lot
in the middle of a movie that's so funny
it really is kind of a whirlwind of
emotions
which i really really like because if
it's just too funny all the time right
it has no seriousness to it at all uh
that can be a mess but i think
taikawatiti did a really really great
job of kind of blending in these moments
that were a lot more serious a lot
deeper and there are some deep moments
where you're just kind of like dang
that's deep so i think overall the movie
blended really well together the plot
was fantastic the story was great the
cgi was on point the fights were on
point the villain was on point
everything was pretty much on point
except for those few things that again i
had a little bit of a problem with but
overall the movie is amazing it's
fantastic i love it i hope everybody
else loves it as well i'm curious to see
what everybody thinks it comes out this
week so i'll do another spoiler review
very soon where we can all kind of talk
about it and talk about our favorite
parts and the parts that we might not
have liked so much so the movie is
amazing it really is i'm looking forward
to hearing what you all think about it
but in the meantime be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news including my spoiler
review coming up later this week for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof